[Musica]
[Applauso]
pandemia
tre anni fa ci siamo dovuti fermare
tutti quanti mentre io stavo per partire
io stavo per partire e stavo per andare
in America
ero lì che mi stavo per laureare al
conservatorio di Bologna e quindi avrei
dovuto decidere anche come continuare e
proseguire il mio percorso di studi
e diciamo che l'idea di andare a Los
Angeles era proprio Per coronare quello
che è il mio sogno di diventare un
compositore di colonne sonore
però poi con l'arrivo della pandemia in
qualche modo mi sono ho dovuto rivedere
i miei piani e quindi rimanere Nel mio
habitat Io abito a 600 metri di altezza
nell'Appennino tosco emiliano vicino a
Bologna e abitano in un luogo che è
completamente immerso nella natura
talmente immerso che ciò i daini e
cinghiali che a volte mi arrivano
proprio letteralmente nel giardino di
casa ma comunque vivo da sempre a
stretto contatto con con la natura
perché sin da quando sono piccolino da
quando cinque anni i miei genitori sono
trasferiti in questo Borghetto di otto
abitanti all'interno di un'oasi una
riserva naturale e quindi
dove tra l'altro vicinissimo a dove
abito adesso dove Insomma alla fine la
natura era protagonista e in qualche
modo
è stata un po' la mia amica immaginaria
un po' come l'amico immaginario si
potrebbe dire
Anche perché era un bambino un po'
particolare tendevo spesso ad isolarmi
non ero molto socievole e stavo mi
ricordo delle ore ad ascoltare il vento
spesso arrampicato su un albero cullato
dal vento
e poi sono cresciuto fortunatamente sono
diventato un po' più sociale e però mi
sono Diciamo che c'è una parte di me che
ha tenuto quell'esperienza e quindi
tuttora se c'è vento forte oppure c'è
che ne so neve o un temporale io sento
proprio la necessità di mettermi alla
finestra a guardare affascinato proprio
nei dettagli la performance atmosferica
in maniera un po' quasi maniacale è un
po' Strana come cosa lo so
però non riesco a dormire la notte se
nevica per dire E quindi questo per
farvi capire il rapporto che io ho con
con la natura
ma venendo a noi io appunto ho deciso
un po' obbligato anche dal coronavirus
di rimanere a casa e non partire e
quindi si è posto un problema come
faccio da casa mia a far arrivare la mia
musica ai registi o anche semplicemente
a possibili ascoltatori
E da qui che entrano in gioco i social
io ho raggiunto tantissime persone
mediante Instagram Tik Tok e Facebook
e
tra l'altro ci tengo a dire che ero
oltre a essere un po' asociale ero anche
anti Social Cioè mi obbligarono cioè fu
mia madre a obbligarmi a fare il profilo
Facebook a suo tempo mi ricordo questa
cosa qua per farvi capire quanto è un
anti social
e quindi in qualche modo la pandemia e
lockdown mi hanno dato il tempo di
riflettere e soprattutto di fare un
corso di marketing digitale applicato
alla musica
per il quale poi per la prima volta ne
ho scoperto proprio i lati positivi dei
social e anche
diciamo la potenzialità che si hanno
così ho cominciato a pubblicare il mio
progetto discografico per la prima volta
non da dietro le quinte Ma come artista
principale e diciamo che lo stupore è
stato tantissimo nel vedere che i miei
video Hanno cominciato a fare milioni di
follower e milioni di visualizzazioni
sia su Instagram che su Tik Tok e in
poco tempo sono diventato diciamo uno
dei più grossi influencer compositori
del mio genere
però ci tengo a dire che non sono
secondo me le migliaia di follower che
ho oppure l'aver creato un pianoforte
smontabile averlo portato in luoghi
assurdi per fare queste performance che
sento essere il mio extra ordinario ma
in realtà è venire qui
davanti a voi mettermi a nudo per
affrontare la mia più grande paura che
proprio quella del palcoscenico per la
prima volta
e portare quindi la mia musica
comunicando con voi tra parole e musica
sicuramente il modo in cui io comunico
meglio Ecco la musica Ed è proprio per
questo che vorrei fare un gioco con voi
adesso
Vi chiederò di dirmi delle emozioni e io
mediante un'improvvisazione che farò sul
momento proprio estemporanea le
interpreterò Quindi adesso vi chiedo di
tirare fuori i cellulari
inquadrare il QR Code e senza scattare
una foto basta solo semplicemente
inquadrarlo cliccare sul link che
apparirà in corrispondenza da di esso si
aprirà una pagina dove voi potrete
inserire un'emozione
quindi può essere un'emozione che avete
provato può essere un'emozione che
vorreste provare o semplicemente che
vorreste sentire come io la interpreto
quindi Adesso vi lascio giusto qualche
secondo per fare questa operazione
e subito dopo io sceglierò quattro di
queste emozioni per costruirci un brano
un'improvvisazione una sorta di Rapsodia
sul momento allora ho scelto stupore
che vedo in grande nostalgia
curiosità e gioia in questo ordine
vediamo cosa succede
[Musica]
[Applauso]